a robust security Corsica to no longer
have hesitations
its brothers
[Music]
I continue to urge the Security Council
to authorize
the immediate deployment of a
robust international security force which
would assist the Haitian National Police
in the fight against  the gloves
[Music]
today I went to the
Tahitian and Haitian meeting and I felt
the exhaustion of a population that
has been facing a
cascade of crises and
unbearable living conditions for too long.  calls on the
international community to come to the
aid of populations in need
it is a question of solidarity but
it is also a question of
moral justice the Haitian people have the right to
this solidarity
[Music]